bars and restaurants with bar seating
are preparing to welcome back guest 8
News now reporter Kate Houston shows us
the changes they can expect just in time
for the weekend bars across the valley
are preparing to reopen it's good to
support the local taverns here and
support small business United States and
get it back up there during phase 2 bars
and taverns that don't serve food can
reopen at 50% capacity and with strict
social distancing guests wanting to
order a drink will not be allowed to
walk up to the bar but will have a
server come to them it's been a little
different our amazing guests who are
normally sitting at the bar are sitting
at lounge tables they're enjoying our
dining room they're getting a little bit
different feel of your local bar bar
areas within restaurants will also
reopen if you're planning to sit at the
bar it will have to be six feet apart
from other people here at distill in the
northwest they're turning on these
gaming machines and preparing the bar
area as they await even more guidance
from the Nevada Gaming Control Board
today the board announced gaming
machines must be socially distanced
businesses can remove every other chair
or cover a machine amy Vandermark with
distill tells me that they were waiting
for the green light and they'll adjust
their procedures Keith Houston 8 news
now now in addition to social distancing
the Nevada Gaming Control Board
recommends bars with gaming machines
disinfect them on a regular basis and
they also recommend bars make hand
sanitizer or wipes available for all of
their guests to use